Vous avez forcément déjà vu ses petites billes blanches quand j'étais petit j'adorais en prendre sans me rendre compte que c'était un
médicament ces pilules consommée par plus de 50 % des français sont ce qu'on appelle de l'homéopathie
mais est ce que vous saviez que même si elle était vendue en pharmacie et qu'elles étaient prescrites par les médecins
pas tout le monde ne les considère pas comme des médicaments que ce serait une forme de médecine
éthiquement très critiquable. Je vous propose d'étudier ça ensemble. Comment marche l'homéopathie, retournons au Xviiie siècle
cette merveilleuse époque où la médecine s'était un peu du grand n'importe quoi, c'était le bon vieux temps où quand t'étais malade
on t'ouvrais les veines, ça s'appelait une saignée c'était censé t'aider à aller mieux. C'est dans ce contexte qu'en
1796 samuel hahnemann un médecin allemand reprend les bases de la médecine d'hippocrate
selon lui il faut soigner le mal par le mal c'est ça l'homéopathie et c'est en opposition complète avec la médecine classique
pour des maux de tête par exemple en médecine classique on va utiliser un anti-inflammatoire pour t'aider à calmer la douleur alors qu en homéopathie
on utilisera une substance qui causent le mal de tête. Celle ci est censé, en théorie
aider le système immunitaire à le combattre et ainsi aider le patient à guérir plus vite contrairement a ce que tout le monde pense
l'homéopathie ce n'est pas que des plantes c'est aussi des ingrédients d'origine
animale
est autre choses un peu plus bizarres ou par exemple  mephitis putorius qui est en fait des glandes anales de putois ou encore
medorrhinum à base d'un lisat de
sécrétions uretrales purulentes blennorragiques d'un malade qui n'a pas encore été soigné autrement dit du pus de pénis.
Surtout que je vous apprends rien en vous disant qu'avaler des substances nocives
c'est pas sans risque, c'est pour ça que samuel hahnemann à une idée fabuleuse
et si ces substances on les diluait, en soi c'est pas bête, en diminuant beaucoup les molécules actives
on enlève la toxicité et les effets secondaires. Mais, comment ça marche la dilution en homéopathie,
sur les flacons on retrouve des nombres suivis de la mention
ch ou k c'est le niveau de dilution de ce qu'on appelle la teinture mère la base du médicament.
L'homéopathie c'est comme le sirop dans ta grenadine sauf que c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus dilué. Pour faire un médicament homéopathique c'est très simple on prend une goutte de la teinture mère
disons ici une goutte de pus de pénis on la mélange avec 90 gouttes d'eau ou d'alcool, on va ensuite
dynamiser la solution alors le mot il a l'air cool mais ça veut juste dire qu'on va secouer le flacon et une fois que c'est
fait on obtient une dilution 1 ch.
Techniquement la quantité de molécules actives est
divisé par 100 on répète ensuite l'opération on prend une goutte de cette solution on la remet dans
99 gouttes d'eau on redynamise
et voilà on a 2 ch vous faites ça
Une trentaine de fois mais on peut aller jusqu'a
100 000 dilutions si vous voulez. On prend une goutte de cette solution ultra ultra
diluée et on la met sur une petite bille de sucre voilà tu l'as ta bille homéopathique
voyez ce tableau c'est le nombre moyen de molécules dans ta bille à 12 ch il y a autant de molécules de pus de pénis
que dans tous les océans de la planète au dessus de 12 dilution il y a statistiquement plus
aucune chance qu'il y ait une seule molécule active dans le médicament et à 40 k cela
représenterait la dilution d'un atome de pus de pénis dans tout l'univers observable
vous avez bien compris ta bille c'est du sucre à 100% mais avant de vous expliquer la thèse derrière l'efficacité de l'homéopathie
Connaissez-vous l'oscillococcinum
et si vous connaissez ces pubs que vous voyez à la télé état grippaux
aussitôt  oscillo. Ce médicament censé traiter les états grippaux. Pour faire la teinture mère de l'oscillococcinum
on utilise en fait du foie et du coeur de canard qu'on fait macérer pendant 40 jours oui c'est du jus de canard
putrifié, mais pour faire joli on appelle ça un autolysat mais pourquoi on fait ça ? En
1920 Joseph Roye homéopathe français découvre une bactérie mutante
l'occilocoque, c'est elle qui serait à l'origine de nombreuses maladies notamment la grippe
Pour guérir la grippe justement il décida de faire un remède homéopathique
en implantant ces bactéries dans le foie et le coeur de canard
en diluant les particules de foi et de coeur il concocta un remède magique qui eu soi-disant des résultats miraculeux
sauf que voilà aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait c'est que ce
micro-organisme n'existe pas et que la grippe n'est pas une bactérie mais plusieurs types de virus
à 30 euros la boîte ça fait cher payé les billes sucrée à base de bactéries imaginaires on comprend pourquoi en mars 2012
Boiron a déboursé 12 millions de dollars pour faire taire l'action de groupes de consommateurs
américains qui dénonçait l'inefficacité et la pub mensongère de l'oscillococcinum
ça n'a pas marché puisque Boiron a quand même fait plus de 600 millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires en
2018 soit 50 millions de plus qu'en 2012
Et là vous vous dites sûrement "ouais c'est quoi ça" et vous avez raison
comment un médicament comme celui ci a pu être mise en vente et dans 100% des pharmacies en fait contrairement aux médicaments
Classiques
les médicaments homéopathiques ne sont pas tenus de prouver leur efficacité
seulement de prouver qu'il ne provoque aucun effet secondaire. En gros la seule chose que vous pouvez être sûr en prenant de l'homéopathie
c'est que ça vous rendra pas plus malades.
Mais comment justifier que ces billes aient le moindre effet. Bah oui parce qu'il y a une théorie derrière ça. En
1988 un chercheurs publie une thèse dans le magazine Nature
Nature c'est pas n'importe quoi une thèse censé prouver que l'homéopathie peut fonctionner
c'est la mémoire de l'eau, les chaînes de télévision s'affolent, c'était enfin la preuve qu'on attendait pour prouver que l'homéopathie
marche. Selon le chercheur l'eau garderai en mémoire les propriétés électromagnétiques des substances avec lesquels elle a été diluée et
dynamisé cette théorie permettrait d'expliquer pourquoi malgré de très forte dilution les médicaments homéopathiques
garde des effets thérapeutiques.
Pour résumer très grossièrement la thèse, on met de l'adn dans un verre d'eau on
enregistre les fréquences émises et on fait écouter ces fréquences à un autre verre d'eau, si on donne à ce deuxieme verre toutes les protéines nécessaires
He bien l'eau serait capable de reconstituer l'adn du verre précédent
juste en écoutant les fréquences. Comme si l'eau pouvait enregistrer des informations
du pus de pénis pour les restituer dans la capsule de sucre et je vais pas vous mentir quand on ecoute des vidéos dédiées
ça a l'air crédible il y a tout, des notions compliqués de la physique quantique et surtout un peu de magie qui a l'air scientifique,
de quoi titiller l'imagination mais, il y a un problème aucune étude sérieuse n'a réussi à trouver des résultats similaires,
en science on doit pouvoir prouver que ces résultats sont réplicables sinon ça n'a aucune valeur et on comprend bien pourquoi.
Je vous rappelle que l'eau du robinet c'est de l'eau qui a été filtrée dans des centres d'épuration,
macérant des jours entiers dans la merde de millions de français et si l'eau a une mémoire elle doit être
traumatisé et vous la buvez tous les jours. On peut trouver beaucoup d'études portants sur l'efficacité de l'homéopathie toutes les étudier demanderait un travail gigantesque
mais ce n'est pas le genre de choses qui freine les scientifiques.
En 2015,la N H M R C l'agence de santé australienne a synthétisé les résultats de 176 études basées sur l'efficacité de l'homéopathie
leurs résultats, il n'y a aucune preuve que l'homéopathie est efficace et pire
choisir l'homéopathie à la place d'un traitement qui a fait ses preuves c'est mettre sa santé en danger.
Pourtant certaines études montrent que l'homéopathie est efficace est-ce que la N H M R C ne les a pas étudié ? He bien si
mais, ces études étaient soit de mauvaise qualité soit sur un nombre de patients trop faible pour être
crédible, en gros meilleur est l'étude plus elle prouve la non efficacité de l'homéopathie
et le N H M R C n'est pas le seul organisme à avoir fait ce genre d'étude, cependant ils arrivent tous à la même conclusion.
mais certains vont me dire mais moi l'homéopathie j'en ai pris plein de fois et ça a fonctionné et vous avez raison
l'homéopathie d'une certaine façon ça marche "et là dans les commentaires
déferlement
de rageux" Je vous explique l'homéopathie c'est comme un bisou magique de votre maman sur une blessure,
techniquement c'est encore ouvert ça pisse le sang mais, vous savez moins mal, c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet placebo. Ça ne vous est jamais arrivé de ne plus avoir mal à la tête juste après avoir pris un doliprane,
pourtant est ce que vous saviez que le doliprane il faut au moins 15 minutes pour commencer à agir. Même les médicaments efficaces
profitent de l'effet placebo et c'est pour ça que votre médecin continue à vous prescrire de l'homéopathie, une surdose de doliprane ça peut être mortel.
Une surdose d'homéopathie ça n'existe pas, si vous continuez à avoir mal à la tête vingt minutes après avoir pris votre doliprane
augmenter la dose ça serait dangereux pour vous mieux vaut que vous preniez plus de ces petites capsules en espérant guérir avec ça eh oui
l'homéopathie
sauve des vies. Partout dans le monde on se méfie de plus en plus de la médecine,
on se tourne de plus en plus vers des médecines alternatives, des alternatives
parfois dangereuses qui vous font vous tourner vers des plantes où les surdosages sont potentiellement mortels.
"Ha la j'ai l'impression de me sentir mieux"  "voila"
"Par contre je sens plus ma bouche"
"Ah oui ça par contre c'est des orties monsieur...."
si vous vous tourner vers l'homéopathie au moins on est sur que rien de mal va vous arriver
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter avec des pharmaciens et pharmaciennes qui vendaient de l'homéopathie
et même eux sont d'accord sur le fait qu'il n'y ait aucune preuve de leur efficacité
mais refuser d'en vendre serait un énorme manque à gagner et puis avec deux jours de formation pour devenir médecin homéopathe
pourquoi s'en priver c'est donc un business qui fait vivre beaucoup de monde notamment les pharmaciens et les labos de recherche.
Oui jusqu'ici la sécurité sociale
finançait la recherche en remboursant c'est billes de sucre.
Ceci dit tout ça touche à sa fin car la france décide d'arrêter le remboursement à partir de 2021. Alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
de tout ça. Prochaine fois que votre grand mère vous dira de prendre ces granules magique penser à lui montrer la vidéo.
Cette chaîne est là pour ça vous apprendre des trucs en debunkant des petites choses de votre quotidien.
Du coup pensez à vous abonner, on vient de créer la chaîne.
C'est important pour nous symboliquement, et c'est cool pour vous car comme ça toutes les semaines vous pourrez retrouver une nouvelle vidéo
c'était ma tartine et neoxys
merci à tous les monteurs et tous les rédacteurs.
Aller les amis !
Chiao!